they're called neutrinos and billions of
them pass straight through our bodies
every second neutrinos are some of the
strangest and most mysterious objects in
the universe they're invisibly tiny and
can travel through solid rock and even
stars as easily as they do through space
100 trillion of them every second FL you
and I reckon they might do you some good
but no one knows yet nutrino neutrinos
shooting All Around Me oscillating
soundly impacting
tiny ghosts called neutrinos are they
faster than light they out of sight but
they might hold the universe upright if
you put a 100,000 of them on one side of
a set of scales they wouldn't even
outweigh a single electron 1930 Wolf gly
the scolly Nino existed but they thought
he was twisted and resistant even
listening your theory is farle you
talking about star trickles neither you
nor me will ever see these tiny
particles P's under turn in a word flips
of the bird he got the map to back it up
even if it seems
ABD
then goes to Adam B when in the 1950s
Fred Ry is the new Bambino going nuclear
to find neutros he finds them grinds and
proves they exist there must be zillion
shooting out from his sun and I Miss
Davis can't resist he wants to look
inside the Sun CH on the neutrinos is
how it will be done it's a nuclear
furnace far enough to not burn us he
goes about finding nutrino and nus then
he comes up short just a third of what
should be there no feir nutrino
Vanishing in the thin air
[Music]
the 60s the 70s the 80s go by this guy
keeps trying and dying is is a quick and
lying no one's buying what he's selling
the numbers are telling but there must
be something wrong but he won't change a
song but now there's three kinds of
neutrinos we find electron Moon and Tow
all Flying Blind like B we can't see we
need a plan B another experiment this
time in Japan but man the results to the
same Lane game when they count tros it's
less than they claim they should be you
kidding me when we go down in history
zillions of dollars and we still can't
solve this
mystery now some people are saying these
neutrinos are playing with our eyes No
Lie the solution is n three kinds of
neutrinos they really the same particle
imagine an article of clothing that
keeps changing the state they started at
one thing but late when we colate it's
too late they areolate and to another
con we'll never relate that's why they
seem fewer we got the wrong viewer we
can't detect and say all three kinds of
flavors in fact there's probably more
neutrinos in the universe than any other
particle that we know and yet
paradoxically we know less about them
than anything else
almost masatoshi kosa is the new kid in
town and the Japanese mountains is where
things going down with super kamande
chamber so Grande you can basically see
the path of neutrinos from points A to B
he proves what they're stating inros are
[Music]
oscillating
one more scenario this time in Ontario
inside of mine to count the neutrinos
all three kinds this time in 2001 the
results come on strong the numbers
belong the Skeptics were wrong that
crazy Ray Davis was right all along
there still might be particles will
never see but definitely they're more
than debris and a time of Trinity
shooting All Around Me oscillating
soundly impacting profoundly tiny ghosts
called neutrinos that they faster than
light they out of sight but they might
hold the universe
upright